bonsoir ça va bonsoir en mati très bien
en un peu en retard non non non c'est
parfait moi je suis je suis venu à pied
je sais pas conduire donc je ne vais je
ne dîne klaus balayait
leur faisant forme m'écoute oui je
reviens de suisse j'ai respiré bonnaire
des montagnes tu es dans une clinique
pour tous on ne prend forme
wind on avait dans un hôtel simplement
chez mon ami cambuzat ah oui oui je vais
de temps en temps
désintoxiquer chez cambuse à wengen x
est un bon hôtel c'est tout je te
rassure ça lance
on te voit pas trop quand même à la
main non mais tu sais moi je
lundi j'ai refusé d'aller à une émission
de
dechavanne s'est pas du tout aux côtés
de sharon si c'était une émission tu
sais il fait une nouvelle émission je
n'avais fait une sur la corse que
j'avais vu en suisse d'ailleurs les gens
seuls et là c'est une émission sur le
retour de l'ordre moral est alors au
départ j'étais censé faire partie des
dix ont des libertins et alors d'un côté
il y aurait eu les gens pour l'ordre
dans l'ordre la morale est en moi
j'étais censé parler contre la morale
est une chose et ça je refuse que j'ai
c'est le principe que je refuse déjà
qu'on nous met une étiquette sur le dos
moi je souffre on comptera beaucoup de
cette étiquette du libertin peu moins d
agir absolument rien dire moi je peux
être je suis aussi peut-être je voudrais
bien venir dans une mission parler de
morale mais sans qu'on préjuge donc
quand je serai déjà c'est du sable il ya
des étiquettes spécialement à 80 alors
on va le pousser à oui oui je vais des
femmes au chocolat mais si vous savez
beaucoup
isa est une
magicienne
voilà on va goûter attention
mais ça doit être dur à la télé
aujourd'hui pour trouver des gens qui
veulent venir incarné les amoureux mais
ça je ne sais pas mais il va avoir du
mal parce qu'il ya on est en plein dans
leur moral donc c'est sûr que pour
trouver quelqu'un qui veut venir jouer
contre les moralistes ça c'était
difficile ce qu'est ce qui est l'ennui
la télévision séquelles enfin la
télévision deux des meilleurs j'ai
peut-être des médias en général c'est
que tu n'as
pas vraiment souvent le temps de
l'expliquer et que très vite le public
a de toi une image qui comme sienne si
elle est caricatural ici ensuite le
mois après certaines émissions notamment
je pense un pivot par des derniers
apostrophe tu vois et bien ensuite
j'ai eu des ennuis même de gens qui
montent à poster dans la rue des choses
comme ça moi je préfère me dit privée et
ma tranquillité à la littérature j'aime
bien littérature mais je vais pas
commencer à avoir des accrochages avec
avec des dames très très bon chic bon
genre dans les magasins franchisés quoi
par exemple obliger monsieur
tu vois des trucs
mais jeudi mme hamm qui avait voulu de
moi mais je n'ai rien
n'était alors dans ce cas là
adressez vous adresser la parole d un
écrivain que vous avez lu écouté qu'est
ce que c'est mais je vous ai vu à la
télévision était madame un écrivain
c'est pas la télévision un écrivain cc
libre enfin mais tant que bon temps dans
une société normale
c'est pas grave on s'en fout mais
maintenant il ya une espèce d'hystérie
général et donc à ce moment là il faut
être un peu prudent parce que tu te
livre pas envie de zapper boucs
émissaires de je ne sais quelle campagne
ou de je ne sais quel
[Musique]
les fans siècle sont spécialement bête
ouais écoute la fin du xviiie
robespierre qui coupe les têtes au nom
de la vertu les libertins les athées
tout le monde on coupe la tête c'est la
vertu c'est vraiment la fin du 19ème
oscar wilde à reading dreyfus à à l'île
du diable la vertu aussi et maintenant
la fin du xxème siècle entre monsieur
reid alors il ya eu reagan il ya eu
comme annie n'y a eu en bonne 2 et le
sida en animant 4 fléau qui ont rendu le
monde fou voilà il savait prix alors
c'est vrai mais simple on est prêt pour
les champignons
l'argentin mal de champignons qui avec
un tissu de tomates des oignons confits
de trucs
merci
juste et mora dans ce monastère
ggg cueillir des champignons mais sans
certaines combinent bien manger
d'accommoder par les moines que par
isaac
mais c'est normal que les gens aient du
mal à
comprendre admettre que tu puisses être
à la fois écrivain d un sulfureux tué en
même temps où tu as envie de te retirer
dans des monastères et c'est un peu
imaginent pour les gens c'est
des gens ils mettent tous dans des cases
toutoune a décidé qu est surtout donc
place à l'est mais je crois que moi
quand je leur dis que je suis royaliste
et que je fume des pétards pour relier à
ceux qui fument des pétards y avait un
voyagiste
c'est une race qui n'existe pas donc
c'est pareil ils ne connaissent pas bien
l'histoire la monarchie sans ça ça
mais
en fait moi je je je pense que tout le
monde est pétri de contradictions mais
seuls les artistes les exprime si nous
étions
artistes ont vivent seuls les artistes à
ans vivait sans nourrir
donc on avait dit
il faut commencer à écrire à quel âge et
coûte en fait je donc j'ai écrit comme
tout le monde l'a 13 14 ans des petits
trucs et je pense même des poèmes les
choses comme ça mais je me vois me
mettre au fond ce que le déclic il ya du
moulin à poivre tout un peu de poivre
le déclic ça a été
ça a été quand j'ai commencé à tenir mon
journal mon journal intime vers quel âge
16 ans 16 ans 16 ans et demi à damas 17e
année il se raconte pas d amour
non non non je terrain était pudique
j'étais en plus de ça maintenant je sais
qu'un pli
l'adolescente plutôt chaste m et seul et
très révolté d'entrée suicidaire très
très tournante et c'est pour ça que j'ai
commencé avec le journal quand je me
suis senti très tôt le journal c'est le
confident qui on dit des choses qu'on ne
dirait pas son meilleur ami qu à
l'embellie que c'était le défi non le
défi c'est quoi c'était en 65 il ya
juste peut être un tank du plaisir je
fête mes 30 ans de vie littéraire s'il
fait un peu hein
ce qui ne nous rajeunit pas pour ce soir
mais c'est bien quand même
santon oui trente ans de vie littéraire
et
et tu sais au fond
moi je pense qu'on récré toujours le
même livre il faudrait expliquer au
public c'est moi si j'avais une émission
littéraire
les sujets ne sont en rien que les tous
les sujets c'est la page de transworld
24 ans et les faits divers de parisien
libéré en soi parce que tu veux sanaa
les sujets appartiennent à tout le monde
un sujet c'est rien ce qui fait le skiff
et des olives c'est le ton c'est senna
pas propre de l'artiste il n'y a pas de
bons sujets n'aurait sujet de l'économie
semble intéressante a quand même eu des
centres d'intérêts effectivement je
parlais du suicide tue près d'une île il
ya les amours adolescentes des ans c'est
quand même bien des thèmes récurrents il
ya des thèmes obsession obsession mais
je veux dire c'est m en soi
comment dirais-je ces thèmes en soi ne
sais pas ce qui s'est passé thèmes qui
sont intéressants c'est la façon dont on
les traite longtemps après ce qui
t'arrive aujourd'hui c'est comme tu t'es
intéresser beaucoup à des amants à des
amendes jeunes
aujourd'hui on ne retient que ça on
retient pas le style dans lequel ça a
été fait c'est ce que je dis on retient
le sujet plus que plus que le traitement
finalement tous les sujets les sujets
ont connu les sujets encore si c'est les
gens qui me critiquent avait la
gentillesse de lire les livres a
tendrement il dirait que dans ses romans
où effectivement les héroïnes
les héroïnes sont très jeunes ont des
romans d'amour ou des passions partagées
et c'est l'analyse de la patience et
études de la passion et la description
de la passion qui je crois est belle
donnant un exemple
je peux le dire parce que cette jeune
fille vanessa je les rencontre t elle
m'a inspiré un roman harrison plaza
c'est là qu'on s'était vu d'ailleurs je
devais interviewé par là
et ensuite un tome de journal intime qui
vient de paraître en folio qui s'appelle
lui la prunelle de mes yeux mais c'est
la même gêne personne qui m'a inspiré eh
bien j'ai rencontré vanessa dans un
dîner chez ma directrice littéraire
[Musique]
divorcé
et
bon le vie n'était pas intéressant
[Musique]
je suis
faux donc bien
[Musique]
à mon tour
une semaine
[Musique]
tous
il
bientôt
non
je ne suis devenu son amant nous sommes
des diamants que plusieurs mois plus
tard on avait déjà 14
ans creek non c'est pas ça je veux dire
je veux dire que ça a été une conquête
présente est réciproque qui veut dire
que le jour mais ça défile chez moi
elle avait aussi envie et moi vivions
tous les sens et ensuite quand j'ai été
dénoncée jeudi à vendredi il n'y a pas
que il ya eu des les fans est une sicav
en france est une grande ambition
n'arrêtera n'anime de jimmy j'ai
d'ailleurs dit ferrer les lettres
anonymes et maintenant des amis de ses
parents parce que la mère avait réagi
comment la mère a respecté la passion la
mer du nord aurait dû intervenir elle a
compris que c'était une véritable
passion réciproque sa fille dit si tu es
si tu savais qu'à briller avec l âge à
l'école moi j'avais j'avais quarante
neuf ans et je dois dire que j'ai fêté
mes j'étais très déprimé les déboursés
par exemple effrayant d'avoir 50 ans
imagine dans les romans de dostoïevski
on dit que le vieux car à mes yeux
un vieux 45 contre hors de moi
il ya j'ai vécu moi j'y suis né au mois
d'aout qui viennent je suis
nous sommes devenus amants vanessa et
moi mois de début de l'été en fin du
printemps début de l'été j'ai vécu la
nuit j'ai de mes 50 ans et la journée on
attend est resté 48 au lit dans les bras
l'un de l'autre
j'étais absolument merveilleux de passer
ce demi siècle dans les bras d'une
sublime beauté 14 ans garçons
actionnaires et bien vanessa était prête
j'ai été dénoncée gt1 tournée d'un et ça
était prête à aller voir françois
mitterrand pour délit en soi même je
vais l'épouser si on m'avait envoyé en
prison n'importe quoi donc elles étaient
passés par cet amour et donc c'est ça
que
au 6e rang de mambo extrêmement
respectable je sais où elle a
dirigé la garder de tout garder
relations après on va pas avec vanessa
ses enjeux
on s'est revus parfois mais c'est trop
dur et trop dur on sait maintenant je
deviens blanche en les 6
et
non
maintenant on est là
300 personnes
non mais je si j'apprenais demain
qu'elle a besoin de moi
est ce que quand il ya une telle
différence d'âge est ce que ça ne lit
pas les sexes est ce qu'on peut pas
quand on a un certain âge qu'on a eu des
relations avec des gens beaucoup plus gm
est ce que finalement au bout d'un
moment ça devient pas assez indifférente
sur des filles ou des garçons
toutes mes grandes passions n'ont été
on était des filles un moment de ma vie
mais je dois dire que
c'est vraiment pour moi le passé un
moment donné quand j'étais très jeune
justement tu vois ça je suis pas
d'accord avec toi c'est plutôt quand
j'ai joué 17 18 19 ans j'étais très
sensible au charme d'un jeune garçon est
d'ailleurs dans mon journal de
l'adolescente qui a paru en librairie
des
pensions il ya c'est vrai il ya plus de
jeunes garçons que de filles
non je veux dire que celui
je pense que bon non
mon journal ni roman est une chose mais
le livre qui élira le crous en ma faveur
et ça je lui ai dit l'autre jour
gallimard ont crevé c'est un recueil des
lettres d'amour que ces jeunes filles
m'ont écrit sur vn ça je pense que si ce
livre quelques y paraître après ma mort
mais si on peut faire ce livre moi je
n'y a pas de passe et ça serait le plus
beau tu vois ça serait mentir mais la
déception a dit en absolutions
absolument jean dernier parce que ce
soit des gens disent oui mode sleep in
avant tu sais qui n'existe pas il a
fabula toit soit il les a rendus très
malheureuse
vais l'être quand une jeune fille décrit
quand même des lettres de passion et
d'amour pendant trois ou quatre ans ou
même 200 m cinq ans ou même plus c'est
quand même donc ça fait un ensemble et
ça sera des très belles lettres parce
qu'en plus de ça il ya une génialité
d'adolescence surtout pour les femmes
nous restons géniaux gourou bull en mai
je paie c'est vrai c'est terry s'est pas
mise au lit ce que je dis je voudrais
pas que ç'a paru misogyne des portes
j'avais un petit peu mais pas trop c'est
qu'il ya une géniale et chez les
adolescentes qui qui se perd lorsqu'elle
entre dans l'âge adulte et je vais dire
pourquoi c'est parce que ces
adolescentes ont été géniales dans quel
était rebelle ou notamment présentés
comme des enfants mais un jeu un jour
elles sont récupérées les maires dire
pour écrire mourani de la ville sur les
maires sur les mers et sur les relations
de mutiler les maires et quand quelque
chose de très importantes très fort avec
une jeune fille
keller 13 qui est tout à fait de ton
côté contre sa mère par exemple en toi
même tu te dis un jour c'est la mère qui
l'emportera il reviendra vers sa mère
mira
et les maires gagnent plus jeunes non
c'est pas une époque très drôle non mais
nous nous sommes tus et il faut être
supérieures à son époque s'il faut pas
non plus laisser démoraliser moi je
trouve qu on les emmerde à pieds en bois
qui me démoraliser bofa c'est vrai quand
on a connu sans être stèle chez mais
c'est vrai qu'à une époque
c'est beaucoup plus zen comme en a donc
atterri
au co
[Musique]
mais tu vois ma gêne jobs j'aime l'art
les icônes et les visages de jeunes
filles et bien de même j'aime cette
cuisine où il ya du soleil
c'est cette espèce de mélange de cette
utilisation
à partir d'une cuisine très classique
française préalable la haute école de la
cuisine mélanger les aromates des
saveurs mettre en mode les reviennent
s'attrape pas bon frédéric magnus
médéric ousmane youth
[Musique]
m'écoutais je suis très fier interrompre
cette conversation mais c'est qu'on en
dise en fait c'est une émission sur les
sur les coiffeurs nettoyer les coupes de
minima et rex plus parce que si tu veux
c'est une
non et bien m'excuser avant et après oui
ça car ça c'est ça c'est beaucoup plus
difficile et puis dire plus car moi ce
matin j'étais en votre honneur messieurs
je suis allée chez le coiffeur j'avais
tous les huit jours toi tu peux y aller
une fois par an ça suffit moi je suis
fier mais non tous mes droits d'auteur
pas son coiffeur c'est que ce vin auquel
je souhaite récurer lancé 13-17 du
château chalon on dirait du qs et les
rencontres est mort m ais je pourrais
avoir autre chose
que du sincère les à
guillaume gille à derrick avec l'acia
laviolette
violet
mais moi je voudrais un truc dans un
verre genre une poire ou un truc comme
ça tu avais déjà dit ne pouvoir
m'installer vraiment dans un mois on va
on va faire ça merci je sais que je le
regretterai
non mais c'est vrai je suis très je suis
ému de voir gabriel à chaque fois que je
vois je suis ému parce que
quand j'ai publié mon premier roman à la
table ronde il était là il avait même
écrit la quatrième de couv me souviens
j'ai toujours admiré ce parce que la
plupart des pourra pas faire comme c'est
une émission qui est différent des
autres va pas faire du lèche vitrine
mais c'est juste une parenthèse parce qu
est-ce qu très traditionnelle vous
demandez ce que très moderne
mais on the mais c'est vrai que dans la
merde actuelle d'un milieu des lettres
complètement pourri
les magouilles et cetera il a toujours
était toujours intégré incroyable et
tout le bouquin qui sort l'a donc vous
avez déjà dû parler
mais on n'a pas baissé plus intéressant
que deux internats c'est un recueil
d'articles alors tous les titres qui
écrit les articles quand on lit les
législatives de nourissier compagnie
c'est bâclé c'est mal écrit et cas alors
que
je suis fier mais on pourrait citer
plein de gens j'ai envie de me griller
comme jean ce soir car maintenait
toujours bon c'est ça qui est incroyable
qui soigne au style toujours toujours
même dans le moindre petit truc que
personne ne va lire dans une frangine de
province dans le film un des trucs
faciles et il soit une écriture et sarah
respect respecte
barrès disais que la à propos de ses
chroniques line la réput la réputation
du chocolat menier est dû à sa qualité
toujours égale il sait qu'un écrivain
dos des plus faibles dans une petite
chronique d'un journal d'étudiants et
dans une page de romance et de contrôle
de qualité
label matney alors là il ya de la
cocaïne
ils ont mis 2 h un truc sur le nom c'est
un truc pour toi tiens prends ça je sais
tiens prends ça tu vas voir c'est un
truc qui va me faire aller au chien ça
maintenant pour ça c'est bien je le
prends avec le château ça
me touche beaucoup
ça me touche beaucoup il a compris ce
que si vous voulez bouger tellement bête
que j'en ai un pour moi janyk 2006
moi j'en prends aussi pour te montrer à
quel point
non mais il faut expliquer ce qu'il sait
et attend est-ce que c'est du cloud mal
atterri dire ça je veux pas dire ce que
c'est un terrible c'est que même sur le
câble ont expliqué tu veux aller là ce
soir je te pose la question à toi
puisque tu insomniaques mais après
deux ans et demi
et nous on va aller voir des buts de 62
ans pourquoi
les gamines de 12 ans et demi et lui
dirai avec des
noms ce que je ne sais pas si c'est moi
je te suis là c'est toi c'est ta tournée
un
son tout a déjà été écrit peu rien n'a
d'intérêt
maintenant ce n'est vraiment respirer on
vérifie alors c'est bon et c'est légal
au moins donc ça va on peut on peut les
diffuser le sucre glace
c'est pire est passé tu t'es passé dans
une autre bonne émission des bonnes
minutes j'avais vu par l'oreille ouais
souvient début par laurel comme quoi les
seules fois où je fais les choses
brillantes c'est quand il ya thierry à
la table un métier stimulant et entre
temps il dix années se sont écoulées oui
et j'ai rien fait d'intéressantes design
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu